hello everybody my name is Matthew
Rockland or continuum I work on this
project called blaze there's been a lot
of hype about blaze I'm just going to
turn to talk sort of very basically
about how it works and again after this
Phil's going to talk about actually
using it and getting some numbers out
okay so very briefly so the too long
didn't read on this is that blaze is an
extensible interface for data analytics
so helps you do queries like numpy and
pandas queries but it doesn't run numpy
and pandas it runs other systems or runs
postgres or it runs [ __ ] or runs out of
core things so it's an attempt to sort
of bring sort of the pipelining system
outside of in-memory computing it does
that not through building a new database
rather by letting people use their sort
of familiar interface to access existing
technologies technologies like spark or
Impala or manga or postgres okay
motivation this community is really
based around tools that have been based
around the numpy and pandas libraries
these libraries sort of foundations on
which lots of our tool sets exist you
know scikit-learn and matplotlib you're
both talked numpy arrays and pandas data
frames and that common interface those
data structures I've really allowed all
of us to work on many different things
and use lots of different tools it just
pick up tools at random and know that
they'll work together okay but numpy and
pandas limited pretty much limited to
in-memory computing and that's sort of a
limitation as sort of data sets get
bigger as we have many more cores to use
that becomes challenging and so want to
grow that uses an outside of that space
we're sort of thrown into this Wild West
situation where you've got one of you
know what 10 20 different things you
could use and you're not sure what to
use and even if you're sort of fine want
to choose one you've a lot of learning
to do a lot if there's lot of new things
to play with okay so let's sort of
challenge into this challenging to
branch out outside of in-memory
computation and that's sort of the the
thing that blaze is trying to trying to
okay blaze is just a user interface so
it's just sort of something you type at
and it's also something like a compiler
it is something that sort of takes the
thing that you type and translates it
into something that some other system
uses like sequel or [ __ ] curries okay
it is for analytic processing not for
transaction processing so things like
pandas are numpy not things like Redis
familiar with that okay it is not try to
replace that' bases north of title place
pandas it's just complimenting them with
interface okay so what I'm gonna try to
do here so i usually give talks about
this topic I lots of slides and the
sides just sort of boring because it
just looks like pandas all the time like
oh well like I already do that so why do
I care right so I'm going to try
something new something scary for me i'm
going to try actually interacting with
blaze live and so please be be kind okay
so i'm going with this thing called data
okay data i'm going to move this a
little bit hopefully you'll still hear
me if that doesn't work let me know
okay so I'm going to wrap data wrap
blaze around a single Python integer
okay so here's that integer rap with
place this is a blaze thing and that
plays thing looks like any other ensure
right but if I actually look at that
thing as a string will see that blaze
has actually been creating some
expression for me so I've that's been
typing things starts been sort of
recording what I've been typing as I
sort of rep right to the screens are
pictured the screen actually does some
work okay so there's a separation
between what we're typing and what
actually gets computed a slightly more
interesting example whoops let's play
with a you know sort of a tabular like
data set and we'll give it some some
names to play with and again this looks
exactly like pandas and we can do
exactly like pandas things second
exactly like pandas things here we'll
find all of the accounts with it with
negative balances will get out their
names oh dear thank you for telling me
yeah okay looks like pandas let's
actually go one further and just have
this is have blazed drive a pandas
dataframe directly and again exact same
experience so whether or not blaze was
driving pandas or Python lists we saw no
difference now blaze wasn't doing work
it was telling pandas were selling
Python to do work in the first case it
was writing for loops and Python was
doing excuse for loops in second case it
was calling pandas functions and pandas
doing the work so we saw the same
experience than user experience with
appreciably different performance it
guaranteed presumably pandas was faster
we said well I already know python
already know pandas so I would ever use
blaze the interest want to go outside of
these two systems so for example we were
to create a sequel alchemy table see
clock muser project that translates sort
of Python code into sequel Cody Ross
many different dialects postgres my
sequel Impala hive whatever other things
we can have blazed play with that too
right and so this object you know looks
and feels a lot like a data frame so
blaze has gone into this table checked
out the metadata and has given you back
this Python proxy object that you can
interact with as though you're playing
with Hannah's data frame so let's do our
same computation it's a little bit
different because it's a raw things and
we call this thing and so what blaze
gave me back was a sequel alchemy select
statement so if I give bleh the sequel
alchemy thing gives me back to see cloud
anything I give the dependence things
gives me back at pandas thing that give
it a Python thing isn't occupied on
iterator okay then we can sort of used
sequel alchemy then to print out the
sequel that's that's relevant there so
blazes doing this work seek welcome he's
generating the sequel because that's
great Christy clocking these great at
generating sequel
late is just driving seek welcoming so
let's give the more fun example there's
this lawmen baseball bat a set so this
is there's a database I'm pointing blaze
at a CPL light database and we can sort
of look at this whole database and see
the tables that are in there is this
team's table more space there's this
team's table there's salaries table and
I'm actually driving going into the
database and doing work there and bring
results back let's join these two
and again this joint is happening in
sequel itís not happening in pandas
we're not pulling data from the database
until we absolutely need to and let's
let's compute let's do this let's
compute by joined I want to sound do a
split like of mine operation on a group
by the team name and the year so that's
grouped by year ID and name and I want
to find the average salary that'll be
joined salary
so this is holly different syntax from
from pandas sort of a combined snakes
been changed a little bit but it still
sort of gives you the same feel and now
if you were doing a split apply combined
operation is happening in sequel light
we're getting results back we've only
actually fetched enough results print
something to the screen but we could you
know we can push this into
dear already wrong
so actually the fact that i got an error
is interesting so got an error instantly
blazes it was hell that I did something
wrong as i was typing the thing he
didn't have to go out to the back end
and compute say oh the back in 20
something wrong happened lazy able
because has this proxy object can sort
of tell me immediately that I've done
something wrong so let's look at that
file so here's my result so what I've
done is I've operated in a panda's like
way but I've driven a for an execution
environment sequel light in this case
okay but it still felt familiar to where
would like pandas can have that same
experience nice thing about sequel light
so then I suppose Eagle alchemy is once
you touch sequel light you've also
touched postgres in my sequel and Oracle
and other things so my friend Ben who's
great put up this little Impala cluster
uneasy to hopefully
there we go so we're actually going up
to ec to work my way up to ec2 we're
talking to ana paula database I'll take
a second you can see what's there and we
see if there's just tripped data thing
there and this is the new york city taxi
cab data set the motorway people talked
about this earlier today and here you
know sitting on some some ec2 box or I
think this is a very small cluster of
four boxes or something but this could
be a arbitrary large cluster and then we
can interact with it in a very smooth
way you got all this how to complete
stuff it sort of feels very natural and
so will do as little computation exif
data dot medallion and we'll find the
have this somewhere so we'll find the
total passengers and we'll sort by the
passenger jet that's going to take a
little bit so we'll go back over here
emphasize some main points blaze is not
pulling down into memory it's this work
is happening elsewhere on a c2 but we
still have the same sort of nice panels
of experience blaze can drive a variety
of things through c clock me drive all
the sort of sequel technologies it can
do país park relatively Rusli numpy and
pandas like technologies MongoDB other
things like that wow that's happening so
ever here so i want to sort of so that's
what the first part of the talk is
that's what blaze is it's an interface
that you can use that feels natural that
drives foreign technologies that's sort
of international food is now which we
want to go a little bit deeper in a
second before that happens I want to
sort of motivate something so most of
the products that we like a couple a
high level interface something sort of
nice to use with a low level
computational engine something that's
very fast okay numpy and pandas both
have this feature there's this blue part
which is this Python code that we like
interacting with there's this white part
that runs fast and that combination is
really nice but as we said it sort of go
outside of that world we sort of have to
get certain wealth of things to choose
from that's challenging
so you might you know choose sequel
which has sort of one single interface
but letting different implementations
I'm sure that go to the no sequel land
sort of lots of different interfaces for
every different thing you can go to sort
of the high performance computing land
with very little interface right but
very high performance there's things
like Hadoop and spark poopin sparkling
is a nice example here so when you
choose a technology you choose it both
based on performance guarantees and
based on the usability do I know this
technology can I like read the tutorial
well and we choose those technologies
based on both of them maybe we shouldn't
it be sort of unfortunate that we choose
we have to sort of make both choices at
at the same time spark is a good example
because sparks for the sells itself is
this in memory Hadoop alternative as
much faster at certain class of
algorithms most people that I've talked
to who you spark use it because it is so
much easier to use in Hadoop high-spec
in particular one message it's like
tryout pi spark is actually really
usable you also use iceberg through
blaze but like it's also good on its own
all these technologies are good on their
own so blaze is just an interface
there's no white part which is blue and
blades sort of sits at the center of the
Python ecosystem using various Python
technologies to access all these other
technologies so for example for sequel
use sequel alchemy for [ __ ] we use
pymongo for pi spark spark we use PI
spark so blaze is really a customer of
all the other tools people have built
and sort of one cohesive view onto them
okay
let's so I'm to switch from that sort of
high-level blaze through a diesel
technical topic in the interim is there
a time for maybe one question so you
sort of swap things in and out does it
work so the question is does this work
with Amazon redshift or more generally
does this work with food with food being
some some database that I like right so
the answer answers two answers one this
one rushed up have a sequel alchemy
dialect it might and if so the answer is
yes many things work with sequel alchemy
databases that are sort of relational
like or lease provide some sequel like
interface can often be made to work with
blaze if they can be made to work with
sequel alchemy making see Kwame dialects
is relatively cheap for example the
Impala thing was done by irreligious in
that cloud era and I think a couple days
we had a blaze issue like oh we should
make a sea clock alchemy dialect Marie
came by made the dialect and the next
day we had blazed interactions so
generally speaking making blaze
connections other databases is very
cheap and we have time we'll talk about
how that's done you might think that
making blaze in blaze interpreters from
blaze other databases would be an
expensive hellish process and in some
cases the deed it is but it's it's sort
of designed to be highly extensible you
can you can make that thing without
touching most other parts of place ok
thank you for the question ok so I am up
at 1155 is that accurate oh sorry I'm
from California 55 past the hour
ok I think I have 12 minutes so so on a
quickly talk about high level thinking
and low-level computation and this will
feed in a little bit to what is going to
talk about before we talk about the with
blaze I want to use sim pie which is a
project dear to my heart simply as
another project that sort of does math
it's like Mathematica I mean simp I you
can write expressions in Python and they
become mathematical things they're just
Python objects represent math we can
make you know complex things if we want
this is it goes much more complex than
this and the nice thing about sin pies
you can also hear think of things at a
high level and then using the screen
after you've set about things about high
level you can generate numeric code that
is you can sort of switch back down to
low level computation so let's put some
transcription so for example sin PI R
knows how to emit C code right so you
can sort a copy and paste this into a
function or you can have various things
right and umpire thunks for you and you
know there's no reason to stop it just
see you can also generate fortran code
or if you're particularly masochistic
you can generate JavaScript or I mean
I've actually really like this one this
one's very nice running papers okay
logic yeah see ya um and so we can sort
of think at a high level and operate a
low level right we don't have to do got
to choose one or the other and
particular this is nice because we can
actually do some non-trivial thinking at
the high level so you know this is
really simple can do a lot of things but
doing very simple things like
derivatives or a second derivatives and
we can combine that high level thinking
with our low level code generation okay
and even more so we can you know this
expression looks like it might be able
to be simplified a little bit so simply
has this simplified function and indeed
it can and so by thinking both at a
high-level and low-level were able to
write more efficient code be able to
think very short of mathematical about
our problems we're able to generate high
performance code better than maybe a
human code even sometimes so I don't
need the same thing with blaze I want to
think about data algorithms so blazes
just like senpai but rather than doing
Calculon trigonometry it does linear
algebra relational algebra so we can
think about those things to plop is ate
a lot of the optimizations that you
would find in a traditional sequel
system some of those you can also find
inside a place we can you insert
projections you can remove on unused
things it's nice okay let's see so I
don't have time to do this in an
interpreter
but maybe
that's not the right
there we go oh by the way just as we're
doing this if you go to blaze that pi
dot org and you go to presentations
about blaze you will find these slides
as well as notebooks much much cleaner
notebooks than what i've been doing here
in a console draw everything's there for
you with pros so everything you can do
in your notebook right now I'm going too
fast just to demonstrate that I will
just go back to my slides okay
so I'm play the expressions we can so
again we can write these sort of very
abstract expressions using blaze up any
data attached there's actually no data
present we're actually just thinking
about computations we can sort of reason
about the shape of things that we have
the data types in everything that allows
a lot of those please be very
interactive with you without touching
the form data and then if I have a bunch
of different data types of pie spark
instance is spinning up we have the same
data in a list a data frame and a spark
rdd you know sparking well that is if
you don't worry about it the thing as
we're gonna take the exact same
expression the sort of deadbeats
computation finding everyone with you
know a negative balance we're going
peuta against a list data frame in a
spark ready d and we get back is a
Python thing a panda sting an RDD thing
the spark thing so here we've explicitly
separated out the intent of what the
user wanted that they communicated with
us to an expression the sort of abstract
thing with the data the data is
completely separate normally users don't
do this you should not go home and use
this code this is what happens
internally but i want to show you how
explicitly separated these two things
are and we can defer to make spark
actually do work i think we type in
collect here gosmart go okay
okay so in a couple minutes I want to
show you that's sort of an idea that
sort of basic idea there that blaze
separates out your expressions your
intent from your computation but making
that separation we're able to do lots of
nice things with the focus on you I
separately focusing on data right people
making numpy making pandas they're
usually thinking about they're very
smart guy is thinking about like exactly
these algorithms work they're also
forced to simultaneously think about how
users want to interact with their code
now they're also very good at that too
but it sort of nice to think about one
separately from the other so bleh this
place allows that attack them for people
sir this is want to extend blaze this is
how we organize our code so what you're
seeing here is three functions that all
compute the expression head to give me
the first ten things first five things
first two things on one piece of kind of
data the first case is how we compute
head on Python iterator we use the PI
tools function take the second case oh
wait that's first cases pandas second
case is Python third case its spark and
so blaze is written in this way there's
lots of little small functions they're
all collected together I never run into
I want to sort this spark idd
it's in sort by name
it goes and finds the right function and
this function runs on the data that I
had so to sort of answer your question
this is how we sort of extend blaze to
new things and this actually the
separation makes it very easy to do that
so spinning up a new back end if you
know who duped to comes out tomorrow it
takes us you know on the order of a week
not only order of months so you've seen
lots of product let's present come out
said like oh we've got pandas like
things on spark or we've got you know
sequel running on CSV files always sort
of pairwise things and blaze tries to
handle all of them sort of it makes a
framework to make building those things
more easy ok please also does
n-dimensional things imma skip that
blaze is a language that can help you
interact with many tools I don't claim
that you should learn exactly this
language only this language I don't
claim that it supports all tools but yes
you're right that blaze attempts in sort
of the grand scheme to be one interface
for lots of analytic processing systems
so yeah you can use blaze and connect to
MongoDB trivially who knows how to use
[ __ ] oh that's actually more than I
thought that's great here I'm connecting
to a github like there's a mirror of
github posted in the Netherlands that
you know i was on a MongoDB longer
database i think i'm connected over
there
sure
let's try that again
this does work I promise this connection
issues I'm contacting across the
continent okay I'm out of time so um
okay quickly yeah very quickly so let's
talk about designing algorithms
abstractly away from data sets so
particular sort of going towards the
goal sort of a parallel out of core
numpy or pandas data frame so i have a
10 gigabyte file at four gigabytes of
memory how do i compute on that i'm
going to show how you could use pandas
and some outer core structure like hdf5
or b calls to do that work imagine I
have a trillion integers in an umpire
ray I want to find the biggest one how
do I do that any suggestions
right so one solution is just iterate
over the right over the array and just
in just compute max's as you go okay so
that what happened in Python stage
that's exactly a totally usable solution
that you can do right now and your
interpreter it'll be somewhat slow
though cuz we have to use Python any
other solutions divide and conquer so I
could split the array into lot two
different pieces Pete the max in each
piece and then sort take all those
little Max's and compute the max of
those pieces right right so that's sort
of a chunking solution right so here
that's the solution not chosen and blaze
knows how to do that place actually take
an abstract computation max I tell you
how to compute that thing a lots of
pieces and then together so we do the
same thing let's blow this up a little
bit we do the same thing with some it's
actually the exact same algorithm some
all of the individual chunks then add
all those things together because we're
complicated to do something like Count
count lean on number of nominal elements
well there's 900,000 in this chunk and
there's 800,000 over here so there's
seven times over here on out all those
numbers together so I need to count on
each chunk and then some the result okay
so it's a little more complicated let's
say we do the mean if the trunks are not
equal size we need to some each chunk
and find the count of each chunk at the
end we need to sum the sums and some the
counts and then divide okay so blazes
able to do all these things in the
abstract right here's this little a
combined operation just a number of
occurrences of something so please able
to actually a fairly broad set of things
in this chunked way here's an N
dimensional reduction so I've got a
10,000 x 10000 x 10000 array of XY
coordinate pairs I want to sum the x and
y points to find the variance and the
result is there so please don't mean you
should not understand this quickly but
the idea here is that plays can think
about these things in abstract and then
we can use numb pyar pandas things that
plays knows how to deal with already in
memory and we can sort of use them for
twice so by using numpy and pandas in
memory containers and using plays to
think just figure out what operation
should be done we can build out of core
parallel backends fill in about five
minutes it's going to talk about this
and hopefully do a demo is that right
Phil can you do a little interpretive
thing yeah we're trying to move data to
my computer today and it's taking way
longer to move the data that it is just
to compute on it which is another
problem okay so blazed an abstract
system that does sort of two things for
you for users it helps you use foreign
technology so as a first half of the
talk a lot of girl in the room were
probably just interested in that right
you can use blaze to access and paulo
access spark and it'll feel like pandas
that's use case number one for
developers blaze actually they're really
nice place to start building other tools
i can use pandas in hdf5 to build out of
core pandas in about 100 or 200 lines of
code so you'll see Phil have some
numbers on that I'll be fun so sort of
two use cases ones for the novice use
case one the expertise case blaze in
general have to finish up so blazer this
general abstract system helps you use
other things it also sort of sits at the
center the ecosystem so it's a good
place for a sort of further
experimentation further information can
be found at blaze a pie dough to org you
can install it with Conda and you'll
just talk to us ok thank you guys